ciao ragazzi e benvenuti in un nuovissimo videooo
come potete vedere sono in compagnia di
ludovica pagani e oggi parliamo di
tipologie di ragazze single
buona visione e ci vediamo alla fine del video
mary stavo pensando perché non ti fidanzi anche tu cosí facciamo un pó di uscite a 4
te l'ho detto mille volte mi avete rotto con sta storia del fidanzarsi io sto bene da sola
va bene io non ho bisogno di nessuno per
essere completa io mi completo da sola
ma c'era mica un tipo che stavi sentendo ma chi ma quando ma va ti ha scritto adesso
ma é mia mamma ma come é tua mamma luca é tua mamma certo
ciao tu ciao bello che bonazzo che sei ma
preferisci le more o le bionde dicci chi preferisci
vuoi il nostro numero ciao ciao ciaoooo
io già lo vedo che arriva in sella al suo cavallo bianco e mi porge la mano dicendomi sali
amore mio ti porto a palazzo a
conoscere il re mio padre si stai un pó viaggiando
con la mente forse massi perché l'amore
lo percepisco nell'aria che arriverà
arriverà e sarà magico fantastico
ne hai visti di film della disney eh
ecco si sta dirigendo alla porta sta uscendo eccolo oddio ci vede lo tengo d'occhio io
sta andando dal portinaio e adesso si sta dirigendo ore 12 verso la palestra
oddio in palestra dove c'e' quella che gli piace oddio vai dai vai scappa scappa
non chiara non esiste sono in riunioni tra venti minuti falli richiamare dopo che ti
devo dire cioè ma ti rendi conto
poi ci chiedono perché non siamo fidanzate
cavolo 24h in ufficio io son fidanzata col mio lavoro non mi interessa bisogna fatturare brava #businesswoman
volevo qualcosa di vaporoso ma non troppo bello stretto in vita con un corpettino a forma di cuore
con un pó di perline di swarowsky
poi il velo lungo lungo ma il velo di cosa di cosa stai parlando del mio vestito da
sposa è già tutto organizzato la wedding
planner sa già quello che deve fare e
lo sposo dove lo troviamo ma mi han
detto la chiromante mi ha detto che lo
troverò entro piú o meno sei mesi quindi io già mi son portata avanti capito
e già tutto organizzato tu sei invitata tra
l'altro ecco mary l'acqua grazie mille
anche lui lui chi cosa il mio ex beveva l'acqua anche lui non ce la faccio troppi ricordi
la senti l'aria si anche lui la respirava anche lui io lo amo ma ancora io lo voglio
ma sono passati due anni non la supererò mai mai me ne vado basta
beh allora alla prossima tanto il mio numero ce l'hai ciao baby
ciao amore sono appena uscita da casa di giulia ma va ieri sera abbiamo
fatto le brave siamo state a casa
ma no non far cosí vedrai che ti riscrive dai non ti preoccupare sará impegnato
fanno tutti cosí non mi vuole nessuno tu sei sempre fidanzata io sono single a vita
non mi vuole nessuno ma vedrai che lo trovi eh arriva quando meno te lo aspetti
vabbè ma che schifo tutto questo slinguarsi ma che se ne vadano a casa son quelle cose che
iniziano tutte a bomba eh fuoco di paglia ma lui poi le starà già mettendo le corna
meglio single che cornute ma dai
purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine del video spero tantissimo speriamo che vi sia piaciuto fateci sapere con un
commentino qui sotto
a quale di queste tipologie di single
appartenete e se non lo avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino al tasto d'iscrizione infezione e seguiteci anche su tutti gli altri social tutti
stalkerateci bene ci
vediamo al prossimo video e spammatelo
ovunque amici parenti a tutti
a ruota noi ci vediamo al prossimo video
e chissà se ci saranno altri video
insieme in futuro un bacione
ciao